you're kind of busy doing e you dressing
up you playing dress-up on e mmm now
let's talk about that outfit for a
second because my friend said watching
your boys at your boy Brendan Schaub on
on E
by the way what there's this dude named
Chris who I box with and he's a it's a
big kid he's actually gonna have his
first pro fight and he's just a big big
guy he played semi-pro hockey and he's
from Boston kind of a rough guy and he
kind of looks like you not as
good-looking as you but but kind of
looks like you he's in you could if you
didn't know you and you hadn't really
seen you but you'd seen a glimpse of you
you would go and in a dark room and them
like you fall there's a drought yeah and
there's a girl I know who was with her
husband and she thought you were him and
so she just kept looking over and kind
of smiling and I was doing my jokes and
he thought she was into him and he's a
big thug like he's a big like I said to
him I go what's the what fit what's uh
he said this girl asked me what's the
craziest thing I got away with and he
goes I said I told her bank-robbery and
all he's a good fella and she was like
hi man he was like it was funny is that
I was telling the truth anyway and I was
like oh [ __ ] like he's yeah he's yeah
he's a Boston rough and but anyway long
story short he thought she was trying to
hit on he looks like the alley cat
version of me
Boston yeah like a rough looking dude
and he came up and started hitting on
her husband you're not mad at that suit
came this well let's go back to the suit
of Klein Epstein tuxedo what is that
it's a custom client in Epstein they
make yeah yeah yellow is a burnt orange
mm know what it is it supposed to be
like a gold like a cool yes polluted
river yellow I like the yellow you don't
mind I'll ever mind it see most people
go with the black tux I find that's so
boring no no I like it yeah I get man
every time I hear I thought them the
makeup lay [ __ ] up my hair but
whatever yeah there's a right there your
hair looks like it's not sure what it's
doing
I know your hair isn't it right now your
hairs fighting the front is a Slayer
this way front guard it's like messing
the fries what it got you in the
like why are you going over the side
over here man let's all work together
here it's like our country your hair's
like our country nobody's really talking
to each other it's a melting pot yeah
it's a melting pot and everybody's
fighting I always do my hair myself and
then I thought you know what they're
professionals let them do it and that's
what I got never doing that again
that's a problem because they are they
did calm did they call so many calyx my
hair's a nightmare yeah you know who
Frances McDorman is yeah she had an
Oscar and got stolen from her table Oh
Andy this guy actually took a selfie
with it he got a rest of it he stole it
he stole her puck and this one there
were you do yet well she's from three
billboards she was the big winner of the
night
oh he's in the same art you like breath
like to say might you do bro
he thinks that be goodbye histo histo
thief what did Francis baby give it up
so he just tells her what did we offer
our team just probably just crazy he's
just a thief
walking away he looks like he'll stare
down the word and hold you down so I
could bet what foul though that's pretty
bad asset you took it from like how did
you get that you just took it off the
table yeah that's what she's right I
just left it there
damn some press oh yeah cuz everybody's
talking you don't expect anybody steal
your goddamn no that's a hostage move
got into the Oscars who knows this week
anyway France hey also we don't know
he's gate you don't say what's up baby
boys and we saw baby boy's baby girls
that's a common expression I've heard
that before
I've been called baby boy I'm sure you
have no no I'm sure you have your baby
boy just swallow this baby bird no I
don't do that whatever like I don't
think about putting it in my mouth oh
you know I don't think about I'm not
touching a dick you don't say I mean
this guy today salt just got the whole
cockatiel I got a shower I'm sitting
there I'm sorry my phone
and I looked up he's cutting the bushes
yeah he saw the pipe bro they were doing
work on my [ __ ] house and I'm talking
about 15 minute my roof and I would get
out of the shower they could see me I
would get out of the shower and I would
not for a second over to hover my dick
up hey you [ __ ] guys that's my house
you look at my dick is shut up and do my
roof and it's fine just we're all fine
here let's just act like I don't feel
looky-loo don't be don't be lingering on
my piece how does even bear size that
well you're welcome you like speak up
yeah
here you go boy I'm a big guy with a
small piece so what it was it the hot
summer's day soak this in yeah drink it
in there it is
sure I'm Brenda shop and you can just
see the head sure I'm a pointer but you
know what no I didn't take a cold shower
why are you asking me that the moisture
it looks like your giant elephant I got
a big [ __ ] personality a big [ __ ]
mouth and our [ __ ] mushroom and a
positive attitude mushroom cap with a
positive attitude fellas how about you
how about I make you some lemonade and
he'd come and run a train I'm a grower
not a shower you know my mother-in-law
who I love so much yeah and she said she
goes well I mean I'm Anna needs an
oxygen tank around Brian because
apparently I suck all the oxygen I was
like that's a terrible thing to mess and
my wife cuz I always thought you loved
yourself like beyond anything I go I why
I hate myself on this turn the therapy
is over dinner what's going on it was
dinner and then we had couples therapy
and she was like he said he hates
himself and I was like but I'm a comic
did you Jo did you just pull that card
out to save some ground like we're
things going bad
I've done that before my self what ha ha
oh my friend does that my friend has a
hit when he's devold emergency bridge
he's divorced but his wife was a
nightmare and a [ __ ] nightmare to the
point where they they started fighting
and they were fighting in therapy and
ten minutes in the therapist goes ok ok
ok I think it's a long time this is not
do you guys should get divorced oh wow
that's it she said what a nice day ok ok
ok like that you usually honey dick you
and drag you along
Oh st. $200 she goes you guys are you
guys are absolutely not about ten
minutes he got divorced but Huestis when
they said a fight she'd be freaking out
cuz he travel a lot so he'd go uh and he
grabbed his heart and she got what you
guys my heart my all right she would
immediately go I thought the diversion
yeah I do it myself
yeah the girl bed play dead just how sad
the old possum did you ever see this a
long pause so my just if history got
caught cheating on his wife
Honus girl this dude into any and he she
caught him in a car with him she goes
you [ __ ] and they had it on tape
was called cheaters remember that show
dude Dolf do I ever
right staff he got stabbed yes that
[ __ ] Stan [ __ ] right he's old Altman
snitch and I had a problem with this guy
me do meanwhile had a problem with me
well the [ __ ] jumps out of the
car runs and climbs a tree and he won't
get out and it's girls like he's only
did the old cashing treaty she [ __ ]
treat him he did the old cabinetry it
wasn't that high but he was just up like
on those basic trees in the park like
like LeBron James Kevin drop his ankle
no problem right so he's up there like
this and he's like he's like sitting
there and she goes she's like Chris calm
down calm down and he's like he won't
say [ __ ] he's just hiding up there like
this is you guys what are you doing man
don't just set up that rings and he
wouldn't say anything just call mm-hmm
and he wouldn't look at her look at me
and he's not looking at her he's just
staring at the wall that's not a bad way
he ran out of idea it's not a bad you're
you become a child immediately ran and
jumped up we're gonna have a blac chyna
pictures I just randomly brought them up
earlier let me see some blackjack well
show it to Brendan when he's here to you
I see what we're dealing with
so as I'm attractive at all mainly
because I think she seems like a bad gal
that's partly a part of it she seems
mean I don't I don't like um I don't
mind like a mean person actually the
last thing that happened to her whatever
it was her boyfriend the Kardashian guy
he's the one that was well first of all
she cheated on him a lot which was mad
at me but then he's a face right
no she oh yeah he she did that she did
that by do you feel like we're living in
a mean time like a mean culture 100%
since social media had so do I it really
brings out the dark side of human being
yep it just it's like and people are
like um they do some awful things to
each other it's public shaming like just
you know like like somebody that
something said something about somebody
it could be a political thing and then
the other side the trolls on the other
side are are just like sending the worst
most harassing messages they swap them
they they they say BAE there's gone
there there's a standoff and you got
SWAT team outside your house and someone
died recently because of it yeah man let
me see some pictures of this black jam I
look at her body it's it's ridiculous
yeah but this isn't this isn't this a
fake but oh yeah look at look at the
next option for me dude look at this all
I see is a crazy person yeah that is
just i literally just see an insane
human being I'm like well this is what
human beings do you're this crazy it's
it's not gonna end well
right I've always thought about things
that like I got life is [ __ ] long
people tell you life is short taken from
the 51 year old it's long